live in a society where the the old
concepts of virtue which were based on
Christianity have more or less died away
it's not it's not known or understood as
a religion or as a set of principles or
as a moral system by millions of people
who find themselves even so craving as I
think almost everybody does for some
sort of guidance as to how to be good
and here here we have a whole new set of
beliefs which provides a set of guidance
in how to be good the problem is it's
wrong they've not got it right they've
become obsessed with climate change
they've become obsessed with sexual
politics and they've also become
obsessed and this I think is the result
of a definite campaign rather than a
collapse of the Christian religion
they've become obsessed with with
getting rid of the patriarchy of
actually making a profound and final
attack on what we used to view as the
family I think the real sufferer in all
this is the family and the real gainer
in the end will be the state